hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive it's time to
see what's making the headlines with the
director of the john smith center at the
university of glasgow kezia dugdale and
the conservative commentator tim
montgomery they'll be with us from now
until just before midnight so we're
gonna have a look at what's on the front
pages so far uh we'll start with the
guardian they are reporting the world is
on track for disastrous levels of global
heating despite carbon cutting pledges
at the cop 26 climate summit in glasgow
the metro carries criticism of the
former attorney general jeffrey cox
after it emerged he cast absentee votes
in the commons while carrying out highly
paid external legal work in the bvis the
paper dubs him jeff in paradise
here's the daily mirror it says around
100 000 nhs staff face losing their jobs
unless they get fully vaccinated by
april next year
the eye is warning that care homes in
birmingham manchester and nottingham
could see staff shortages where
mandatory vaccinations are introduced
because uptake amongst the profession in
those areas is low
according to the telegraph the education
secretary nadim zahawi has called on
oxford university to explain to its
jewish students white accepted more than
12 million pounds in funding from a
trust that was set up by the family of
the wartime fascist leader sir oswald
mosley
the ft reporting that the u.s
conglomerate general electric is to
split into three separate public
companies focused on healthcare energy
and aviation
uh quite a headline on the front page of
the start criticized members of the
green party who flew to the cop 26
climate change conference for the last
eco hypocrite to leave cop26 please turn
off the flights
uh the takeover of insurer lv from
american private equity firm faces a
furious backlash according to the daily
mail that's their lead story
and katie price is on the front page of
the sun she's broken her silence over
her car crash back in september
admitting she could have killed someone
i want to discuss those front pages and
more we're joined as i said by kezia
dugdale and tim montgomery uh good
evening to you both
good evening
um right where should we start i suppose
we have to start at cop26 it's entering
those final few crucial days let's take
a look at the front page of the guardian
and it's focusing in on that key target
um of
keeping the global temperature down it
was of course 1.5 after the paris uh
climate agreement cop 26 trying to keep
countries around the world on track um
but the guardian of many newspapers and
including sky news reporting that
analysis shows the world is going to
miss that um tim it's quite an alarming
read when you look at the facts
yes but perhaps not entirely
surprising
we've heard lots of good reasonably good
promises from most of the developed
world in the last week or so and
particularly from the european union uh
largely from north america
but there's always been this issue that
india and china in particular
have been real laggards in this and i
think the the fundamental flaw that i've
seen in
climate change global climate change
policy for a long time is that we
haven't focused on china china you know
can is accounts for well over half of um
the burning of coal for example and it
has plans to build many more coal-fired
power stations and i'm afraid
until the west generally has china china
policy at its heart not only will it not
face up to the climate challenge it
won't face up to the security challenge
or a lot of human rights challenges as
well so
yes it's disappointing but i think
anyone who's really been looking at what
beijing has been saying for a long time
shouldn't be at all surprised that's
interesting i was reading today actually
in the guardian so um you know the the
um today's edition rather than
tomorrow's a special adviser to the
chinese delegation saying that actually
china isn't giving being given the
credit at cop26 it deserves it says it's
doing more than it's been credit for
peak coal consumption by 2025 more wind
and solar power capacity by 2030. that's
more than the entire installed
electricity
system in the united states and it's
pledging to reach net zero
in 2060 at kezia china is a key part of
this but like so many countries they're
saying that their pledges
are doing what they can at the moment
and it's everyone that needs to to pull
together on this is it fair that china
gets so much stick
a certain degree yes i think it is i
mean tim is right the expectations on
cop are huge and they were always going
to miss the mark from the point that we
knew that president xi and president
putin were not going to be there to make
those deals the sunday times actually a
couple of weekends ago ran a story about
china's progress around climate change
saying when you look at it on a per
capita basis they've actually done quite
a lot and there's a few
western centers higher up per capita
league that need to do more than china
do but tim's absolutely right without
china and russia really pulling out the
stops when it comes to things like coal
in particular there's no way we can
reach the 1.5 degree target that we need
to what i would say though is that
despite you know america's presence at
the conference in the past week they're
not really delivering to the extent that
they should either i mean they refuse to
sign up to the um comments around coal
and indeed australia and canada have
also fallen short in terms of being big
consumers of coal so the west still has
a long way to go yes it's important that
china comes to the table but we've all
got responsibility here whatever corner
of the globe you're on yeah all
countries pledging something but the
overwhelming feeling is that nobody is
doing enough no one country is doing
enough and tim can we look at the front
page of the star it's quite the headline
we're the last eco hypocrite to leave
cop 26 please turn off the flights the
prime minister flying back up to glasgow
for these crucial three days and the
star pointing out that even members of
the green party got on a plane to head
to glasgow i think that's what's
sticking in the throat of so many
members of the public who are trying to
do their home is that these big world
leaders and all these delegates are
being hypocritical with what they're
doing quite blatantly as well
absolutely and i should just pause just
for a moment sarah jane for some of your
younger viewers who don't recognize what
the star is doing there was an
incredibly
famous sun front page in the 1992
general election which said that if neil
kinnick then the labour leader became
prime minister in that election the last
person to leave britain should turn off
the light so it's uh this the stars
front pages are quite fun these days and
that's what it's alluding to but
getting to the substance of the um of
the story absolutely right we've seen
enormous numbers of people travel up by
private jets in particular but also by
normal uh scheduled uh aeroplanes and i
think boris johnson as he returns to
glasgow tomorrow is going by train
partly because on after his first visit
he went back to london by a jet and i
think yes you can say that it's
important for people to gather face to
face and i would agree with that and
that's why a face-to-face summit in a
place like glasgow is useful but i'm
afraid a lot of the people campaigning
um on climate change have let the cause
down very badly by using planes that
they then turn around and tell the rest
of us um to avoid and i think there
would be a lot more support from the
general public for action on climate
change if people particularly like the
green party actually practiced what they
preached yeah it's a race against time
at cop26 as it enters the final three
days of negotiations a race against time
on the front page of the mirror kezia
after the health secretary announced
that by april if your nhs frontline
staff are working a care home you have
to be double vaccinated
yes bold move actually from sergeant
javid today to make this call there's
obviously a lead in time between now and
april to give people the opportunity to
get the vaccine if they've been hesitant
up until this point and working in the
nhs they've got the best part of six
months to do so now or they'll face the
reality that they can no longer do their
job on the front line they might be
redeployed to the back office functions
to the extent that they exist within the
nhs or they'll need to seek alternative
employment and this is all being viewed
as trying to protect people as much as
possible within the nhs's own services a
lot of people will be a little bit
anxious about the idea about the state
demanding vaccinations but i think it
does actually feel right and just we've
done i think everything we can to
persuade people that vaccines are safe
and the reality is now that we might
just have to do this in order to make
sure our hospitals are safe too yeah
it's not just hospitals it's care homes
as well front page of the eye tim
care home cliff edge revealed certain
areas of the country should could face
shortfalls and care workers from
tomorrow
yeah i think um this is a really it's a
bold decision i think that's right
because it's right on that from
sagittarius the health sector and i
absolutely understand why the decision
has been taken there's lots of reasons
why you'd want fully vaccinated um
workforce in hospitals and care homes
but just here in salisbury i know a
lovely
romanian couple and they are wonderful
carers of some people that i know
very well
and they are completely opposed to being
vaccinated and they are going to be lost
to the care home system
because of this requirement and um i am
not convinced personally that the the
benefits of having a fully vaccinated
staff are going to outweigh the cost of
losing good people like this who are
really
um effective compassionate carers um
from both the care home system and the
hospital system we're already short
staffed and throughout the health and
care sector and i fear i hope i'm wrong
that this mandatory policy will only
make things worse they're big questions
of course whether it's survive all of
this survives legal tests i think as in
america there are lots of people going
to turn to the courts to overturn this
compulsion and so it's not yet clear to
me
that it will survive um
contact with the reality of the judicial
process yeah a debate that's set to
continue even though the health
secretary has made that decision for nhs
staff and care home workers and front
page jeff in paradise kezia this is
about the former attorney general sir
jeffrey cox who um went to the british
virgin islands to help with a corruption
case there and was voting remotely while
parliament was in session you could say
nice work if you can get it but i doubt
his constituencies in torridge west
devon will be feeling that way
no i mean what what a cracker of a
headline first and foremost from the
metro but you're right this is an
outrageous story at the extreme end of
the the scandal that's brewing now
around the number of mps with second
jobs this is a real extreme example of
an mp raking hundreds of thousands of
pounds at the other side of the world
as part of his second job and that's
been well rehearsed in the papers today
and i'm sure it will be for days to come
yet but the most angry thing about this
story from my perspective is the damage
it might do to the future of proxy
voting in parliament this is the system
whereby mps can cast their votes
electronically that was brought in
during the start of the pandemic we did
a survey of public opinion that john
smith centered about this and two thirds
of the public supported it they liked
the idea that it might help rule rural
or remote mps do their job a bit better
i think they hope that jeffy cox might
consider west devon to be the rural
remote location he'd vote for him rather
than the british virgin isles
um tim your view on sir jeffrey cox
voting from the british virgin islands
doesn't look good does it the
government's having quite the time of it
when it comes to
allegations of sleaze corruption second
jobs earning too much money and not
looking after
the public that have voted them into
those positions
it's a really messy situation for the
government and um i think um this is
going to obviously increase the whole
iron pressure public pressure for
whether mps should have second jobs
personally i think the house of
parliament
is enriched by having parliamentarians
who um aren't just sort of career
politicians uh but this uh story from
jeffrey cox obviously in the bvi um is
not a good advert for the case that
people like myself would like to be
making and tim we've only got 30 seconds
but we've got to talk about marcus
rashford mbes for mum's big example this
in the metro as well
well i'm a man united supporter you
can't really being accused of being
glory hunters at the moment there's not
much glory coming out of old trafford
but um marcus rashford is the exception
he's an exceptional footballer but also
just seems to be an exceptionally
big-hearted person as well and
i love the fact that he dedicated his
mbe as you were
clientele jane to his mum who was his
inspiration for the school dinners
campaign that has benefited so many uh
young children he is a great role model
isn't he tim thank you